first question from ktom24 on twitter
with the trade deadline a couple of
weeks away what trade would you like to
see and what trades are likely had to
happen shireen what do you got
well to me the falcons are in a huge
rebuild i'd like to see them trade julio
jones because i think you get some draft
picks that are much needed that'll be
for a new coach and a new gm that you're
going to get after the season and i just
think it'd be a nice way to start you
have calvin ridley coming up and
he could be your number one receiver
that's one i would like to see do i
think it's going to happen absolutely
not i don't
but that is one i would like to see
happen and then you just look at some of
these losing teams you you'd like to see
them get some draft capital and i i
think
the jets don't have a ton to trade but i
think there are other teams there that
that certainly do that are not going to
be in the playoff picture for much
longer
here's the problem if you trade julio
jones 23 million or thereabouts in cap
acceleration this year this year and
they're already strapped against the
caps so rich mckay's already said that
they don't plan on making any moves with
any of the current roster they want that
roster to be there for the next coaching
staff and the next gm to make those
decisions
but if somebody makes them an offer that
they can't refuse then that's something
that they'll have to consider and
somebody's going to have to make that
decision and mckay is a former gm so i
guess he would make that call in
consultation with owner arthur blanken
interim head coach raheem morris uh for
me i you know it's funny i've gone back
and forth on this now after week one i
was determined that the ravens or not
the ravens that the browns
uh should trade odo beckham jr and then
they went four in a row he had huge
contributions against the dallas cowboys
it looked like it was changing yesterday
visibly frustrated kind of like
old-school new york giants with
everything but the kicking net swinging
back into his face
i i i'm starting to think that they're
going to be better off long term and
they have the running game
i know they're going to need somebody to
come in and be that deep threat that guy
that can be double covered all the time
and who knows maybe they give antonio
brown his next second chance uh it's
worked out with kareem hunt um and
brown's gonna be available in a couple
of weeks but um i just feel like it's
something they need to consider because
i get the impression that that the
desire to win is so overwhelming
that on those days where it doesn't go
the browns way it's just it's going to
be an issue it's going to be a
distraction it's going to be a theme
sharing any thoughts on whether they
should trade obj
do you think they're any different
without him because i don't i think
they're the same team without him as
they are with him and they have austin
hooper and they have the two running
backs and they want to run the ball so
absolutely i say you go get what you can
get for him
a red zone ouch is breaking my heart
here although i am now uh
i i i am apathetic or at least i'm
trying to be when it comes to the
vikings who are one and five is ryan
tannehill everything that the vikings
hoped kirk cousins would be sharing what
do you think
yes yes and yes they both signed the the
contract extensions and or with ryan
tannehill was a new contract but yeah
absolutely he's exactly what the vikings
thought they were getting in kirk
cousins and he's third in passer rating
right now he's uh has 13 touchdowns two
interceptions he's rolling and i think
that's what the vikings expected to get
from kirk cousins and they just haven't
he hasn't been that guy and frankly he
hasn't been that guy his whole entire
career and now
to me they're they're back up against it
because you did sign him to that
contract extension and now
you were stuck with him
cousins has always been just good enough
to not be bad
that's what he's been
and he's parlayed that into
astronomical career earnings because if
you are just good enough to not be bad
your original team ultimately is not
going to keep you and you're going to
become a free agent and how many guys on
the right side of 30 who have played the
quarterback position at a fairly high
level are ever available and that's what
got him the first contract in minnesota
and then the win over new orleans in the
playoffs last year got him and mike
zimmer and rick spielman and dalvin cook
their contract and i'm gary i'm
convinced shireen they're on scholarship
year this year this year doesn't count
next year we'll worry about winning
games this year we don't have fans at
the games oh boohoo you know it's just
this attitude of it's not our year and
it's showing week in and week out and i
think the loss to the seahawks was the
final nail in that coffin tannehill on
the other hand has been awesome he's got
mobility he just and this year
especially i noticed a little bit last
year but he just seems different this
year he's got a different demeanor he
looks larger he looks more confident
he's got a swagger that he's never had
before it helps the more success you
have in any field the more confidence
you're going to have that's what we have
with him that's what they have with
derek henry two contracts they had to do
and uh
it's worked out so far and they're five
and oh real quickly on the way out at
venit virginia should the buccaneers be
better known for their offense or their
defense shireen
uh i think their defense are number one
in total defense they're playing great
yeah you know i agree with you as well
that defense really woke it up yesterday
and they're the reason why the tampa bay
buccaneers beat the packers 38 to 10.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports